emmanuel macron est donc attendu au
kremlin cette après midi pour
s'entretenir avec vladimir poutine sur
l'ukraine maîtres mots de cette visite
désescalade alors que la russie est
accusé d'avoir masse et des dizaines de
milliers de soldats à la frontière avec
l'ukraine en vue d'une potentielle
invasion lna à volochine bonjour vous
êtes notre correspondante à moscou le
kremlin a déjà prévenu lna il n'y aura
pas de percée suite à cet entretien en
clair la france na na pas attendre quoi
que ce soit de cette rencontre
alors cette position finalement ce n'est
pas vraiment une surprise pour emmanuel
macro qui lui même l'a dit il ne
s'attend pas à une percée majeure pour
l'elysée le fait que le kremlin
acceptent de parler avec emmanuel macron
de ce dossier ukrainien c'est déjà une
très bonne chose du coup macro arrive
avec mosca moscou plutôt comme un
médiateur il a dûment consultées ces
dernières semaines ses partenaires
occidentaux autant états unis dirigeants
européens et même canada pour adopter
une position concertée 1 face à vladimir
poutine donc de ce point de vue là il
veut plutôt poser les conditions des
occidentaux et transmettre aussi celle
de vladimir poutine à ses partenaires
qu'il va d'ailleurs continuer de
consulter après sa visite à moscou toute
la question maintenant lors de ces
pourparlers de savoir pour amener la
cour jusqu'au vladimir poutine peut
aller être peut-il aller au compromis et
quelles sont les lignes sur lesquelles
il n'est pas prêt à bouger pour l'heure
de son côté en tout cas le kremlin
maintient la pression il tient ferme sur
ses positions alors même que les états
unis et l'otan ont opposé une fin de non
recevoir à ces exigences qui sont
principalement que les états unis
retirent leurs troupes de tous les pays
d'ex-union soviétique membre de l'otan
et que l'otan elle-même s'engage à ne
pas à s'élargir à de nouveaux pays dont
l'ukraine donc pour vladimir poutine qui
est dans l'impasse a finalement avec
washington et avec le temps emmanuel
macron c'est un interlocuteur plutôt
privilégié lui qui assure en ce moment
la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne lui qui est à la tête du pays
2e contributeur à l'otan derrière les
états unis et puis les deux présidentes
aussi d'une relation plutôt cordiale
malgré leurs différends et donc le
kremlin promet aussi une rencontre
longue de substances qui ira au fond des
choses qui pourraient durer autant dire
que a ici à moscou les journalistes
s'attendent à veiller tard dans la nuit
bien au delà des deux heures allouées à
cette rencontre dans les agendas
présidentielle est bien bon courage
elena volochine on suivra bien sûr cet
entretien entre vladimir poutine et
emmanuel macron avec vous tout au long
de la journée merci à vous